guys you try to shoot this video and
there's a small child outside singing
stop stop
not even a good song I heard I just seem
to spot a hen way way
hey guys what's up welcome to ask IJ
where are you guys asking questions and
I answer them for horrid the most part
how many fishes did I see in Bora Bora a
lot of fishes oh my gosh they're only
letting me pet them
planking music video uh yeah if I didn't
make it by now it's not gonna happen
what what I do for a Klondike bar the
real question is what wouldn't I do what
would I do if I didn't have a Twitter or
a YouTube account favorite show to guest
star on would definitely be Dexter
battle just want to be a victim I want
to be the one that kills just kidding no
I'm not getting
I mean I'm kidding you what I'm not at
all rogue tricks on so now what do I
like most about Diablo 3 well rogue
tricks I like to play it and what do I
dislike about it when I can't play it
because the servers are down why want to
play my games do penguins have nipples I
don't have let's google it lady not did
I hate high school as much as you well
I'm not actually sure how much you hate
high school but considering the fact
that you want to get out of it I can't
really say that I hated high school but
I definitely did not like it as that
saying goes it gets better and I promise
you it does that's so Katie what is your
favorite nail polish I'm not having a
polish at that it's a French honey
moving right along Joey is asking when I
first got my youtube channel and that
was around 2006 holy
that's a long time ago and my first
video was this
I see the all-new purple 3ds yes I saw
it it's beautiful
I want it now for some YouTube questions
if you guys have a question just leave
it in the comments below and I may or
may not answer it in the next episode of
ask IJ what class and level am I on
Diablo 3 my level 46 barbarian isn't she
sexy she scats blue pink and purple
armor totally cool right I was crazy to
me is this isn't even the type of games
that I normally like to play like I am
all about first-person shooters and I
just decided well you know what I'm just
gonna try to yellow 3 I'm just gonna
seek just a play I basically have spent
way too much time on Diablo 3 33 hours
and 42 minutes oh my god I can't even
imagine the amount of things that I
could have been doing that were
productive instead of playing this game
do I get noticed walking in the streets
sometimes usually in Apple stores though
cassettes it's where my peeps hang out
and I play Minecraft because you like
Minecraft actually I do plan on playing
Minecraft now that it's out for Xbox I'm
able to easily capture it so look for
that on my gaming channel your I Jade
you like whales preferably with
mustaches I don't even know what you're
talking about because whales don't have
mustaches do they no don't think so oh
this is a nice question why are you
weird
um I don't know maybe because being
normal sucks these secret talents uh
not really cuz I pretty much post
everything on the Internet
so I need my secret talents like
juggling or barking like a dog are
probably somewhere already online and if
the bark like a dog want isn't online
somewhere let me just demonstrate for
you I have to cover my mouth because
it's a little awkward no I didn't fix
that in post that's that's me I'm um
thank you guys for watching this episode
of ask I J I love you I will see you
guys in the next episode be sure to
subscribe so you'll know what I do live
shows because I just did one the other
day I plan on doing them hopefully every
Sunday but don't quote me your best bet
is just to follow me on Twitter add me
on Facebook and of course subscribe to
my youtube channel so that you'll know
when I do a live show anyway I will see
you guys later peace